salut à tous vous écoutez envergure
voici notre nouveau format spécial draft
2023 ça s'appelle Victor et les autres
une fois par mois on va suivre la
progression de Victor one bagnama avec
beaucoup de précisions en tout cas on va
essayer c'est notre credo envergure et
puis on va aussi parler de l'actualité
des prospects prévus en haut de la draft
avec lui ce qui pourrait concurrencer
womanyama ou en tout cas dans la Green
Room le soir de la draft le père aimait
Hugo ils prennent la main Victor ce fils
dont le destin d'effraya des gazettes
alors à chaque fois trois parties
d'abord évidemment Victor web bagnama où
en est-il quel est son actu que
montre-t-il en termes de capacités
techniques tactique psychologique
ensuite un point sur la concurrence
évidemment et puis pour finir un invité
étranger qui viendra nous parler de
wembi de Vic vous pouvez dire comme vous
voulez c'est ça pas grave l'oeil de
l'extérieur une interview avec un scout
ou un observateur donc soit américain
mais ça peut être aussi européen premier
épisode ce soir ou ce aujourd'hui avec
pour la team envergure pour la première
partie Manu bonsoir
Alexandre bonsoir
Luca bonsoir bonsoir Alexandre je dis
bonsoir mais vous pouvez écouter ça
pendant la journée et Benoît comment
allez-vous monsieur deberto mes hommages
notre invité en fin d'émission sera
Raphaël Barlows coûte Internet que vous
pouvez lire notamment sur NBA big board
dans le monde de Victor c'est plein de
mots en or dans le monde de Victor que
vais-je trouver ta porte
alors les amis on sourit on est on est
heureux on regarde déjà vers le mois de
juin Trave 2023 ou Victor web benyamas
sera-t-il le premier choix il a dit que
c'était son objectif mais il en est où
le français qui est attendu au sommet
d'une cuvée qui est pourtant très dense
on va faire un point on a vu jouer
Victor qui a repris la saison on a vu
jouer en amical on l'a vu jouer en match
officiel de Betclic élite Luka Emmanuel
en chair et en os donc ces dernières
semaines avec son club des
métropolitanes 94 déjà il en est où
physiquement Luca on sait qu'il a deux
mètres 23
taille de 43 d'envergure c'est pas un
exercice ce sont des vrais chiffres mais
maintenant son corps on dit que c'est
souvent la grosse in d'habitude à propos
de lui
est-ce qu'il a évolué par rapport à l'an
passé son corps et est-ce que tu le vois
gêner dans certains déplacements où en
est le corps de Victor web benyama
alors physiquement je trouve que le
corps n'a pas bougé tant que ça mais je
trouve ça plutôt positif parce que on
sent qu'il est beaucoup plus à l'aise
dans ses déplacements
il utilise beaucoup plus son corps comme
une arme par exemple je sais que si Manu
l'avion cher en os il a vu sa routine
d'échauffement ou il se met à 45 il
travaille son job sans bouger mais
tellement que son envergure est longue
en fait on dirait presque une fente et
du coup je trouve que que son corps
n'est pas tant évolué tant que ça c'est
vraiment positif pour lui parce que ça
lui fait
à presque 7 mois de la draft de pouvoir
s'habituer à son à son corps de qui est
potentiellement peut-être dans sa phase
finale je l'ai pas vu en très grande
difficulté physiquement il a dans tous
les matchs que j'ai vu il a jamais
explosé totalement en contact à part
pour flop un peu pour une faute mais
franchement j'étais vraiment
impressionné par à quel point
physiquement
sans vraiment bouger prendre en masse
etc Il a cette up dans le sens où il est
beaucoup plus à l'aise dans ses
déplacements et par rapport aux autres
joueurs sur le terrain il est fluide
quoi c'est on rappelle que c'est quand
même la grande
ce pourquoi il est là ce pourquoi on
parle de lui à cette position c'est
parce qu'il est fluide par rapport à sa
taille que soit techniquement ou que
soit juste dans ses déplacements aussi
tu as vu ça sur sur ces premiers matchs
que ce soit dans les courses vers
l'avant vers l'arrière tu disais au
contact aussi il a il a bien supporté
sur les sur le dernier match que j'ai vu
là il défendait sur Nikolic l'intérieur
du Portel et je l'ai jamais vu vraiment
en grande difficulté même quand
nicochets le poster il a pas bougé en
fait son envergure elle est tellement
longue que quand il se posté ils peuvent
venir taper la balle tu vois en fait
c'est vraiment dur de
de le poser jusqu'au bout et ouais je
l'ai pas vu en grande difficulté
physique en tout cas mais il y avait
personne en face qui pouvait vraiment
aller le vraiment le bourriner c'est en
même temps logique que enfin en tout cas
s'il veut être draftéo c'est très
logique qui domine la bête cliquée
physiquement cette année on rappelle
Luca pour ceux qui connaissent pas
forcément Victor et maniyama quand même
un historique de blessures alors tu nous
dis que ça va bien c'est très bien
est-ce que tu peux juste rappeler vite
fait l'historique de blessures de Victor
oui bien sûr en juin 2022 on a eu la
blessure obssoas qui lui a fait rater la
fin de la saison les playoffs et l'euro
basket du coup
après là je vais parler de plus des
grosses blessures parce qu'il y a eu
plein de petits blessures des entorses
etc en décembre 2021 on a eu la
confusion à l'épaule où il a été deux
mois out
du coup ça a mis la saison ça a vraiment
changé le rythme il a eu du mal après
revenir dedans et du coup en novembre 21
facture du droit du droit si je dis pas
de bêtises c'est un mois out si jamais
quelqu'un à autre chose et du coup la la
blessure qui est à l'époque la plus
inquiétante c'est la fracture du péroné
la fracture de fatigue qui un peu
inquiété tout le monde mais au final ça
c'est pas ça c'est pas renouvelé et
c'est c'est plutôt bon signe en tout cas
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui dans ces matchs
pour ceux qui ne les voient pas il est
il a des des protections sur sur le
corps et si oui à quel endroit
alors en tout cas sur le match que j'ai
vu en live la prépa il avait juste un
strap sur le genou droit si je me trompe
pas et le match contre le porter il
avait aucune protection
particulière il était donc épaule que ce
soit épaule cheville tout ça c'est
ça a l'air d'être guéri exactement
effectivement il a raté le roue basket
pour soigner une blessure qui était pas
si grave que ça donc mais visiblement ça
paye en ce début de saison on va parler
de son jeu on va parler de son jeu
Manu avec toi
l'année dernière donc qui était à
l'ASVEL équipe de Rolling etc descend
dans une équipe avec il a un rôle plus
grand justement on va parler de ça
comment il est utilisé déjà cette année
en attaque et est-ce que il y a des
différences avec son utilisation à la
ouais il y a plusieurs différences avec
las veulent à Levallois il a quasiment
les cartes blanches il fait un peu un
peu ce qu'il veut la dépasse droit mais
il est sur pas mal utilisé sur du je
sais pas trop la zone comment appeler ça
entre le corner et le dunker spot tu
vois cette zone là entre la raquette et
le et la ligne des trois points il est
beaucoup servi par là il y a quelques
c'est point viennent principalement de
là soit il arrive en pleine vitesse il
est servi il va au dunk assez facilement
il monte sur tout le monde soit
autrement il est sur du post bas où il
enfonce il enfonce et il y va ou des
fois il prend des petits fac up aussi à
mi distance de temps en temps il y a des
prémices de pick and roll pick and pop
mais c'est pas encore bien rodé faut on
sent que c'est plus un manque de
communication avec ces avec ces nouveaux
coéquipiers qu'autre chose on sent que
des fois il a envie d'y aller il va il
va rouler mais la passe arrive très
rarement encore mais on il y a plusieurs
systèmes comme ça par match qui
sont présents donc ça c'est intéressant
de voir ça et il s'écarte aussi pas mal
à trois points il a tendance à le faire
notamment sur le corner et 45 degrés
c'est deux spots là des deux côtés
ou pour l'instant sur les deux moi les
deux matchs que j'ai vu là en Betclic
c'était le chou et le froid contre peau
il a pas mis trois points je crois et
contre le Portel il fait deux sur trois
ou les deux sur trois il est vraiment
les deux il est vraiment ouvert
non un il est grand ouvert et l'autre il
fait un espèce de Job step et il monte
tout de suite donc c'est assez
intéressant de voir qui justement il est
servi un peu partout sur le terrain il
peut faire plusieurs choses
et il y a aussi de la il fait pas que
Marie il est aussi intéressant à la
passe ou malgré ses 23 c'est un mec qui
va pouvoir quasiment remonter la balle
punissiez le une passe aller sur
shortroll faire de la passe extérieur
intérieur franchement il est assez
unique là-dessus ou sur quelques phases
il va être un Game challenger en fait
c'est assez impressionnant de le voir
faire ça et du coup il y a beaucoup de
livres par rapport à l'ASVEL ou l'ASVEL
il était beaucoup sur le système avec au
stakoski qui était du système qui
finissait les actions à trois points
dans le corner donc c'est il était plus
il faisait plus ou moins que ça à Las
veulent il y avait pas beaucoup d'autres
choses bon c'était sa première saison
dans un tel club
grandeur Euroligue alors qu'à Levallois
il est quand même beaucoup plus libérée
et libre de dans ce qu'il fait ouais bon
beaucoup de liberté et beaucoup de
variétés visiblement dans ce que tu dis
voilà un peu de alors moi on appelait ça
le secteur zéro quand j'étais jeune et
que je joue au basket cette zone entre
le corner et le dunker spot je sais pas
comment s'appelle en langage de coach
mais je vois très bien soit la base
short corner
toi
bon en tout cas un jeu un jeu
intermédiaire on va dire à mes distances
jouer la carotte
un spot-up à 3 points certains pick and
roll on est plus dans le rôle que dans
le pop pour le moment Manu ce que tu as
dit deux matchs moi j'ai vu ouais ok
après je te dis on sent que des fois il
y a des envies des il y a du prémices de
pop aussi
pour le moment en tout cas aussi c'est
peut-être une consigne
probablement on a vu on a entendu
Vincent Collet pas forcément ravi du jeu
proposé même après match contre le
Portel il était pas content de la
qualité de jeu on va dire donc on sait
pas encore ce qu'il attend de manière
optimale mais voilà on peut imaginer que
l'évolution qui aurait une évolution
dans l'utilisation de Victor onmanyama
défensivement Manu il est utilisé
comment Victor est-ce qu'il y a un autre
grand à côté de lui qui prend les
impacts ou est-ce qu'ils défend sur les
pivots mon Lucas déjà à moitié répondu
puisque il va switcher sur les piqu'n
roll et ce qui va plutôt jouer en drop
et ce qui va plutôt step out comme
comment est-ce qu'il est utilisé quel
est son rôle défensif
essentiellement c'est sur du grand et de
la protection de cercle
c'est principalement comme ça qui
l'utilisaient et il y a quelques switch
défensifs où il a pas en fait soit j'ai
vu moi les deux choses soient ils
restent vraiment planté sur face à son
adversaire soit il fait beaucoup de
drops aussi c'est vraiment c'est deux
choses là en défense quand il y a du
switch qui saute aux yeux mais autrement
c'est vraiment un protecteur de cercle
qui va défendre sur les sur les grands
face à lui les 5 ou mais il a pas peur
d'aller switcher donc c'est assez
intéressant et son envergure des fois il
a un peu des retards je trouve moi
d'exécution mais son envergure lui
permet de de rattraper ça que ce soit
proche du cercle ou même d'aller contrer
des tentatives à trois points alors
qu'il est dans la raquette il fait un
pas et bah le foot est contre c'est
assez ça mais après ouais c'est plus des
sous de fois de concentration ou je dis
mince tac tac et il a un peu lent
là-dessus mais ça va ça va arriver je
pense et de manière communicationnelle
je te pose aussi la question à toi Luca
est-ce que c'est le patron de la défense
est-ce que il parle beaucoup sur le
terrain en général ou est-ce que il y a
d'autres leaders dans cette équipe des
métropolitanes
je trouve que justement il est pas mis
dans cette position où l'équipe est
repose seulement sur lui qui en gros si
un match des réguliers il y a des
joueurs qui vont venir qui vont pouvoir
venir l'aider
je trouve que Ibrahima Fall fight c'est
un choix parfait pour pour ce choix
parce qu'il a il a un profil assez
polyvalent il peut jouer 4 5 et du coup
en fait la plupart du temps
Ibrahima falfight décale post 4 et du
coup je
Victor défend sur les cinq et
sur le terrain il communique la
communication de base sur le terrain
c'est pas vraiment lui qui va venir
crier pour
pour raviver les trous ou pousser ses
coéquipiers mais il n'a pas forcément en
fait à Levallois c'est vraiment j'ai pas
vu en tout cas si Manu t'as vu quelque
chose n'hésite pas mais j'ai pas vu
vraiment de gros meneurs de gros leader
sur le terrain c'est plus une équipe en
gros chacun ses petits flashs en fait
c'est jamais vraiment
à l'unisson tout en même temps ok mais
Manu je parlais aussi de la
communication
sur la défense justement à quel moment
switch souvent c'est le grand qui décide
mais en tout cas en NBA c'est ça qu'on
demande au grand je lisais un article
sur
Azaya Jackson à Indiana qui justement
avait encore des progrès à faire dans le
domaine où il en est Victor de ce que tu
es là
moi je
s'exprime mais ça pourrait être un peu
plus un peu plus fort et un peu plus
franc je trouve mais encore une fois
c'est pas forcément le
leader
par là je vous parle l'expérience tu
vois c'est pas il a pas encore
cette Tora là en fait dans cette équipe
qui est toute jeune et toute neuve ou
l'effet kif à totalement changé
quasiment donc c'est un peu difficile il
évoqua notamment sur le banc il est tu
sens il encourage vraiment beaucoup
notamment sur le premier match où il
prend deux trois fautes rapidement ou
les cantonnés sur le banc et il se lève
il applaudit sur les temps mort il est
là aussi donc
il y a quelque chose et je pense que ça
ça viendra dans le futur plus oui bien
sûr oui il est jeune
il peut le faire mais faut que faut que
ce soit son vrai rôle c'est pas un
leader naturel j'ai envie de dire pour
l'instant
ok intéressant mais en tout cas il y a
pas d'aversion non plus quoi il est en
train de probablement de travailler
là-dessus c'est bien parce que vous
parlez de ressenti à vous deux je vous
demandais c'est quoi l'atmosphère là en
début de saison autour de Victor d'avoir
plein de monde et étrangers évidemment
on aura rafale Barlow en deuxième partie
pour qui était là aussi pour les
premiers matchs mais dans l'ensemble
quelle est l'atmosphère autour de lui
autour du club voilà dans la salle
comment vous l'avez ressenti vous
j'ai jamais vu ça pour un joueur même
pour un jeune ou un joueur français dans
le championnat même Mike James et moins
applaudit au moment de l'intro des
joueurs vraiment que ce soit les petits
ou les plus âgés qui ont pas forcément
une grande connaissance des joueurs sur
le terrain mais dès que son nom est
annoncé tout tout le monde se lève tout
le monde crie et c'est vraiment
impressionnant tu sens vraiment que
toute la salle je le connais les petits
cris son nom c'est vraiment
impressionnant il y a une énorme un
énorme engouement entre les deux le
gymnase est plein il y a vraiment une
tribune entière où il y a que des
soit que ce qui remplissent par des
scouts de billets soit par des
journalistes je sais que quand j'y suis
allé
c'était quoi c'était vendredi soir
contre le Portel il y avait le New York
Times ce qui était là donc vraiment
l'engouement est impressionnant mais on
le savait déjà mais j'imaginais pas que
ça allait être autant aussi fort
effectivement et du coup il l'appelle
les enfants qui crient quoi écrit Victor
écrit Victor ils applaudissent des mains
après Victor ah c'est vraiment c'est
même à Angers
ça c'est ce qui m'a le plus impressionné
même à Angers Angers
en prépa écrit à son nom les petits
c'était vraiment impressionnant OK et
Manu toi qui est ton ce que tu as ce qui
t'a marqué sur le court
c'est qu'il est vraiment mis en avant
par le club c'est vraiment la tête
d'affiche la tête de gondole du métro tu
sens que voilà ils ont envie qu'il
brille et qu'ils ont envie qu'il soit
très très bien un moment il y a le sur
n'importe quoi que ce soit un changement
que ce soit un contre un lancer franc le
speaker en venime tout de suite les
choses c'est c'est assez drôle
d'ailleurs un peu gênant parfois
mais on sent qu'ils veulent qu'il soit
super bien en fait dans le club sur le
terrain en dehors du terrain et il faut
un peu un peu tout pour lui entre
guillemets pour que pour que tout se
ressentent et on voit ouais sur le Yuka
totalement raison sur la salle les gens
viennent pour lui en fait c'est ça
sentant ça se voit c'est c'est assez
impressionnant et il y a des spectateurs
mais il y a aussi des professionnels du
basket qui qui viennent d'outre
Atlantique pour le voir quoi c'est là ça
a commencé c'est le début de saison donc
il y avait pas tant de monde que ça moi
j'ai croisé 4 l'équipe différente sur le
contrepo mais ça va aller crescendo
s'il arrive à performer en fait ils vont
tous venir pour l'instant ça commence la
saison ça commence assez bien alors
évidemment c'est pas encore 100 %
régulier etc mais il y a du il y a du
scoring peut-être des choses à faire à
améliorer du côté de l'efficacité mais
en tout cas voilà il était présent
scoring sur sur ce début de saison on va
pas parler des stades tout de suite on
fera un point dans les dans les
prochains épisodes sur voilà sa
production statistique faudra peut-être
un épisode sur les stats avancés etc
aujourd'hui c'est plus une présentation
globale
la chose qui vous a surpris
dont on parle pas assez sur le jeu je là
je retourne au jeu sur le jeu de Victor
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui vous
a surpris en ce début de saison
Luka Manu
voilà quelque chose qui qui vous a fait
tilt
en bien ou en mal le ça peut être les
deux
moi c'est plus sans mal c'est qu'il
force beaucoup certaines choses
justement pour se montrer je trouve que
des fois c'est un peu trop et du coup il
a tendance à forcer beaucoup de tirer au
lieu de faire une passe ou quelque chose
d'autre ok Lucas
j'allais dire la même chose mais ce qui
est vraiment impressionnant c'est que
qui est soit en réussite ou pas les
tirés va les prendre il se pose pas de
questions
et en fait c'est ce qui justifie ça ça
décision il est dans un système à
Levallois ou voilà il y a des décisions
de quitter Las veulent dire ouais voilà
c'est ça ou il joue aucune compétition
européenne le championnat ça va être
compliqué avec Monaco et et et le reste
donc vraiment il a les clés d'équipe et
il fait il prend les choix qui veut oui
comme l'a dit Manu il force un petit peu
mais
c'est tir là quand il a réussi il va les
mettre donc c'est ça qui est
impressionnant c'est que il a la
confiance de les prendre que que ça
rentre pas
le podcast s'appelle Victor et les
autres on a parlé de Victor maintenant
on parle des autres
[Musique]
on va faire la liste des candidats au
top à les deux trois de cette raftenne
billet 2023 évidemment on va peut-être
se tromper on va peut-être t'oublier des
gens c'est comme ça en cours de saison
il y a des prospects qui se révèlent
surtout à cet âge-là
la chose qui est certaine ce podcast
devrait sortir lundi pour vous public
lundi de lundi 3 octobre
cette semaine Victor one byama va aller
jouer avec les métropolitanes aux
États-Unis face à la jelly gignate il
est mis dans des conditions absolument
optimales jamais vu en France pour être
le numéro 1 donc en pleine saison de
kigalic on fait un aller-retour aux
États-Unis pour on a même déplacé un
match de betrique élite pour ça pour
aller jouer face à la jelly geek night
ou il y a des prospects comme d'habitude
mais pas n'importe lesquels
il y a le numéro 1 bis ou numéro 2 ça
dépend des gens
ça coûte Anderson qui joue à la gilet il
y a d'autres prospects rien dit en
français il y a Sidi Sissoko mais il y a
surtout scout Anderson qui était déjà là
l'année dernière Angelique night vous
avez des podcasts des lives Youtube où
on a déjà parlé de lui c'est hyper rare
ce genre de situation où il y a deux
grands favoris au firspic qui jouent
l'un contre l'autre c'est quasiment
jamais vu alors l'année dernière Paolo
bancaireo et Shetland ont joué l'un
contre l'autre mais c'était pas la même
chose c'était une course à plusieurs ils
étaient pas vus au dessus du lot comme
le son
Anderson alors évidemment il devrait pas
être en opposition directe Victor joue 4
5 plutôt 5 en ce début de saison scout
Anderson qui sait quel prospect il est
ben je t'en prie présente-nous ce ce
jeune talent
scout Anderson de son vrai nom sterling
Anderson est un joueur de 2004 dont il
est donc il est très jeune pour être à
sa deuxième année chez les
professionnels il est un mois plus jeune
que Victor Wayne maniama il va avoir 19
ans en février
c'est mesures officielles sont un mètre
88 et 84 kg mais donc si ces deux 195
livres mais laissez-moi apporter un
grain de sel à ça parce que c'est les
plus grand ouais parce qu'il est
tellement jeune il a grandi là les
dernières nouvelles que j'ai eu qui
étaient CC4
serait à 6 9
c'est un si Victor
de créatures chimérique qu'on a jamais
vu
scout Anderson c'est un peu la vision
idéalisée je dirais d'un meneur à NBA
aujourd'hui il a il a le le corps de il
fait tout les gros malheurs font bien
puis fait tout ce que les petits meneurs
font bien c'est un athlète
extraordinaire qui était capable d'une
accélération
incroyable mais il est capable d'une
décélération incroyable aussi est
capable de jouer sous contrôle de
s'adapter au rôle de ces
de ces coéquipiers
un tout petit peu protégé l'année
dernière parce qu'il jouait derrière
Dyson Daniels il a joué que 27 minutes
par match mais cette année ça va être il
va être le joueur de l'équipe on va lui
donner le ballon puis on va lui demander
on va lui demander
de de créer exactement écrit pour
lui-même et il crée pour les autres
aussi pour un gars qui est un
principalement un score first player il
a quatre points 2 pas décisive par match
pour deux points 1 2.1 perte de balle
pour moi c'est très positif à cet âge-là
il est très très très en avance
d'habitude le ratio perte de balle pas
décisive c'est un un pour les les
passeurs qui sont qui sont en
développement mais lui il est déjà un
ratio 2 si pour amener ce ratio là à
trois ils ont 6 pas décisives pour deux
pertes de balles là on va parler d'un
passeur élite c'est
c'est un premier pas explosif
je l'ai vu battre Jonathan coming-ir
l'année dernière à un contre un
plusieurs fois Jonathan coming out on se
rappelle que c'est un ailier il jouait
il fait 6 8 jusqu'à ce côté
très très avancé ou s'il est pas parfait
mais il y a des Angry Birds il y a
vraiment plusieurs petites nuances dans
son dribble qui qui sont très avancés
pour son âge
c'est
ces deux peut-être ces deux problèmes
c'est justement il y a le shoot
comment il est quand même fait
48.6% l'année dernière sur 3.5
tentatives par match il a le moins fait
passer à John Wall beaucoup il y a le
elbow jumper de John Wall il y a le même
mais ça se gâte un peu plus à trois
points ou ce qui était à 22% l'année
dernière par match sur 2.5 tentatives
mais je sais ce que tu vas me demander
il était à 78% sur les lancer francs
donc
d'après moi ça va se régler il y a
quelques petites
quelques petits détails mécaniques dans
son shoot qui me qui m'agace mais
d'après moi il va le régler bon un
prospect donc qu'on attend évidemment
très haut et qui a déjà montré qu'il
pouvait être fort face à des joueurs qui
ont failli être draftés voir qui ont été
draftés puisqu'il jouent Angelique pour
préciser pour les adeptes des échelles
francophones six four c'est un mètre 93
et l'envergure de 6ix9ine c'est 2-0620
entre deux cinq et deux six
donc c'est les mensurations officieuses
que tu nous as donné mais ce qui me
paraît tout à fait tout à fait correct
par rapport à ce qu'on à ce qu'on
observe sur le terrain
donc ça c'était scout Anderson ce qui
est intéressant c'est que cette saison
ça va être encore plus compétitif la
djilig puisque l'équipe ignate est
intégré contrairement l'année dernière
au championnat de Jelly alors ça reste
secondaire et pas de il y a pas de
relégation voilà c'est pas il y avait
pas un énorme enjeu sportif mais voilà
il y a de la compétition ils seront
autorisés à participer à la saison ça a
participé au playoff si ce qualifie etc
c'était le cas la saison il y avait
jalon green par exemple et ce qui a
permis de montrer à Jalid green de
montrer par exemple en playoff qui que
voilà il était il était un prospect à
surveiller et qui pouvait se surpasser
dans les matchs à en jeu donc ça va être
à surveiller ce scoot Anderson la Gilly
ging night un œil championnat de France
un œil jelly night évidemment il y a des
prospects en NC et et qui peut faire top
2 3 allez 4 Manu selon toi déjà
donne-nous une une petite liste de nom
moi j'ai quatre noms
en parler ouais c'est
Darry kwated de Douk
more Vilanova ouais Jordan walkan SAS OK
et le quatrième non c'est Nick Smith
Scénic Smith mais que j'ai pas vu
le favori c'est Nick Smith on laissera
ben en parler par Le Nôtre heads quel
profil
c'est un grand qui peut être un grand
meneur qui est pour l'instant un poste 2
mais qui commence à sur sa dernière
année à mon neveu Verdi portait beaucoup
là-bas il a développé un bon jeu de
passe notamment en transition c'était
super intéressant et c'est un joueur
post-2 je sais plus si on a sa taille
quelques pas on n'a pas noté là qui est
un jeu assez hybride qui est surtout
porté sur lattes un peu la défense et là
mais c'est pas c'est pas fou fou mais
c'est un gars Ouaka su développer un tir
au fil des années et la passe donc moi
je le vois bien en en grand meneur un
mec qui va pouvoir initier en les
attaques NBA j'ai hâte de le voir
comment il va être utilisé là cette
année
et donc c'est un gamin aussi qui a des
gènes sportifs sont il a un petit frère
qui joue en NFL
que ça c'est surtout un énorme shooter
enfin moi en tout cas ce que ce que j'en
ai vu c'est qu'il est extraordinaire au
tien
ouais si il peut tout faire au tir
quelque chose Jack step cette back c'est
il est vraiment porté là-dessus des fois
un peu trop mais c'est c'est super
intéressant un match que j'aime le plus
c'est ce qu'il a fait l'année dernière
c'est justement cette capacité de
d'initiation et de création pour les
autres ce qu'il avait pas tant au début
et là sur sa dernière année en High
School c'était vraiment intéressant de
voir ça arriver
pour finir la sur lui il y a plein
encore une fois plein de prospects
étoilés du côté de Duke plus à côté de
lui pour stabiliser à la Maine et Roach
qui revient qui est un plus un vétéran
et qui va le décharger peut-être de
certaines responsabilités dans les
moments un peu chaud
qui est plus un gestionnaire je meneur
australien
vas-y Manu je t'en prie en chaîne le
deuxième c'est donc 8 morts Vilanova
qu'on a aperçu lors du tournoi des
Amériques U18 cet été au Mexique MBP non
moi c'était la première fois que je le
voyais en action c'est un bon j'ai
malheureusement j'ai pas si un 98 c'est
il est vraiment tanqué c'est un poste 2
aussi lui qui est beaucoup plus slasher
qui qui est beaucoup dans dans le dunk
surtout la du scoring proche du cercle
et on sur le ce que j'ai aimé moi sur ce
chez ce joueur c'est que c'est on sent
qu'il y a une immense marge de
progression au tir pour l'instant il est
pas fou fou il met dedans mais c'est pas
fou fou c'est pas sa force principale
lui ça force principale ça va être
triple menace et aller au cercle et
dunker surtout mon tout ce qui peut mais
le tir commence à arriver et il y a une
diversité du tir qui est assez
intéressante qu'on a vu au U18 America
donc faut voir ce que ça sur sur de la
NCA de la Big liste
mais c'est vraiment intéressant moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé de voir ça et aussi
quelques flashs à la base notamment sur
du jeu rapide en transition où il arrive
tout de suite il lève la tête vraiment
rapidement et il arrive à bien faire des
bornes pas sous
les passe de mitter donc ça c'est
vraiment intéressant défense aussi
encore un peu à revoir ça va pas être sa
force principale je pense de de défendre
mais il va être obligé de s'y coller un
petit peu s'il peut pas descendre mais
autrement c'est un fort fort attaquant
de cercle pour l'instant
et en plus avec des flashs en pull-up et
en plus alors notre
idole Jay right a pris sa retraite du
côté de Villa Nova mais on imagine que
le système va pas disparaître d'un coup
Vilanova quand même été une école de
formation
fine des prospects dans le déplacements
au football dans la compréhension du jeu
collectif qui ne pourront qu'être
bénéfique on imagine à Kamo hitmore donc
maintenant parlons-nous de Jordan walk
je suis un peu un
il est pas c'est toi tu le mets dans la
dans l'eau mais généralement il est plus
vu vers 7 8 par les Américains je remets
pas du tout en cosmonie mais je dis
juste pour l'instant moi c'est pareil il
est sur mon big board Sonic Smith il est
donc je le vois aussi plus ou moins dans
ces eaux là mais c'est je me dis si il
fait une immense saison ce qui est
possible
ce qui est
imaginable mais qui va être difficile
parce que l'équipe d'Arcole ça c'est les
lahoulis de prospect 5 étoiles je sais
pas comment ils ont sorti le chez qui à
fond les ballons
et jordian Wals c'est un mec assez
hybride de 0,3 de 0,5 avec une envergure
immense qui est capable d'aller au
cercle de faire du tir de faire de la
page de prendre des rebonds de faire des
contre non on l'a observé au geiko
de cette année donc c'est championnat la
finale des championnats de lycéen
où on a vu un gars mais aussi incroyable
pour pour cet âge là en fait il dominait
tout le monde c'était assez
impressionnant de le voir aussi
polyvalent et diversifié son jeu
face à des gros prospects il y avait
quasiment les meilleurs prospects
américains
et le voir être aussi polyvalent comme
ça moi ça m'a
surpris et très agréablement surpris
donc je j'attends de voir mais je pense
qu'un s'il arrive à tout développer
peut-être pas forcément l'année
prochaine
ouais c'est vraiment ça moi ça n'est que
je vais attendre de lui c'est qu'il
c'est qu'il soit plus porté sur le
scoring notamment le 3 points oui il
peut aller aussi arc le premier pas et
pas dingue mais il peut s'en servir
parce que en fait il a tellement d'un
grand pas que tout de suite il peut
faire la différence là dessus mais c'est
vraiment du scoring à trois points que
je vais attendre et qu'il arrive à se
diversifier que ce sur du catching Shoo
de la création pour lui-même création
d'espace pour son tir etc mais mais à
terme ça peut être un grand point fort
word
[Musique]
qu'on imagine et que tout le monde veut
genre un Bensimon avec un shoot quoi tu
vois moins bon
moi franchement j'imagine
à terme d'un mec qui peut être un point
comme ça capable de tout faire et des
deux côtés du terrain
Ben
qui est avec white head allez mais plus
lui quand même qui est vu comme un
candidat sérieux au top 3 quand même
moi j'aime beaucoup personnellement
d'Harry white head là je trouve que
c'est un TOP shotmaker
de shooter mais il est capable de
prendre des choux très très difficile
puis elle fait 5 ans à monter verder
aussi j'ai l'impression qu'il est que y
était toute ma vie là-bas mais oui nexit
2004 aussi aura 19 ans en avril
seulement comme beau garde un mètre 96
84 kg j'ai vu ces matchs cet été en
contre des clubs espagnols ça m'avait
l'air pas mal un gode c'est 5 180 livres
donc les mensurations l'air bonnes ce
petit garçon de la Kenza qui a un accent
de la Kenza ça a coupé au couteau je
comprends rien quand il parle en
entrevue il a signé à la maison dans ce
qui peut être l'équipe d'arkenza la plus
forte que j'ai vu ma vie avec lui le
transfert de Washita state wiki
black donc il y a vraiment un gros
potentiel dans cette équipe là point
d'interrogation sur son père non
seulement il a donné le même nom que lui
mais
a fait l'entrevue de choix de de
pour expliquer pourquoi son fils avait
choisi à Kenza à la place de son fils
donc ça je trouve ça un peu étrange
pour décrire un peu une c'est un tueur
c'est un gars qui est très fin mais qui
est physiquement solide il est beaucoup
beaucoup des Espagnols ont explosé au
contact quand ils ont essayé de faire
des des closades sur lui l'année
dernière
je ne l'appellerai pas présentement le
meilleur shooter de la draft mais il y a
le potentiel de le devenir il y a un tir
à trois points qui est très très réel un
premier pas rapidité va créer de la
séparation sur le dribble ce qui lui
manque en force il va l'avoir justement
en espèce de comme on dit en anglais il
va il va mettre les défenseurs advers
sur ses talons
excellent dribble capable de finir sous
contact
fait des flotteurs difficiles il y a le
gène du Passeur aussi est capable de
fake une base difficile pour détourner
la tension tout le monde pour faire la
passe facile beaucoup beaucoup de de
changement de direction dans son jeu
j'aime beaucoup c'est ça ça c'est le
genre de joueur que disons que tu mènes
par 20 points puis tu veux mettre la
[ __ ] douce il faut que tu l'enlèves
sur le terrain sur le terrain parce que
dans 3 minutes vous allez mener par 50
points
je l'ai vu le truc qui m'a fait le plus
peur avec nexit de le voir contre AMG
Academy l'année dernière quand jouait
pour Noël
AMG Academy avec un autre candidat je
crois peut-être pas top 3 mais top 5 qui
est George
les autres
qui est un très un green flag pour un
joueur de la sorte qui les ont lavés
Nick Smith prenait des décisions
d'affaires en défensive continuellement
surtout en transition en fait donc il y
avait pas l'air d'un gars qui était très
très quand le vent tourne pas de son
côté il y avait l'air un peu à check out
mentalement mentalement du jeu on va
beaucoup le comparer à Jean Morhen c'est
comparaison là sont très
paresseuse et pernicieuse se ressemblent
physiquement un peu c'est tout il est un
peu plus dans le moule de Bradley Bill
si capable de mettre du du un peu de
viande autour de l'os
est un joueur un peu plus à la Bradley
moi j'aime beaucoup j'adore le voir
jouer c'est c'est un tueur
très bien Nick Smith donc vous avez
compris que ça vaudra le coup de
regarder Arkansas cette année si vous
vous branchez du côté de la NSIA
même si évidemment une équipe avec
autant de débutants des transferts etc
on s'attend à ce qui est des difficultés
au niveau des résultats et donc ça va
mettre en lumière le caractère de tel ou
tel prospect ça va être aussi
intéressant là-dessus on finit on
termine le tour d'horizon des candidats
au top 3 avec des jumeaux amen aux arts
Thompson et là on est plus en NCA on
n'est plus angélique on est en overtime
Elite lovertime Elite ça a été créé ça
commençait l'année dernière
et donc c'est un programme qui a été
créé où les jeunes peuvent être payés
contrairement à NCA
même si aujourd'hui il touche des droits
d'image les jeunes peuvent être payés en
overtime Elite ici un contrat et ça les
amène vers la draft NBA ils ont même
signé un cont un accord avec la NCA pour
que ça soit pas
rédhibitoire et qui puisse ensuite aller
ainsi s'ils veulent mais enfin n'est pas
là pour les
précisions réglementaires on est par là
on est là pour parler d'Amen et aux arts
Thompson les jumeaux Tomson vous avez
déjà plein d'articles sur envergure.co
ben on va faire pas trop long sur eux
mais mais quel genre de joueur ce sont
c'est difficile un peu de pas faire trop
long parce qu'on
font les faire les tous les deux
ensemble à chaque fois
pour faire court ces deux joueurs de
2003 ils auront 20 ans la draft sont un
peu plus vieux originaires de Oakland un
petit détail que j'ai trouvé intéressant
dans leur background c'est que leurs
frères ils ont un grand frère qui
s'appelle try Thompson qui a joué à
prairie View et nm pendant deux ans ils
sont ils sont très très familiers ils
sont fait pas très très mais ils sont
familiers un peu avec le processus de de
pour jouer à haut niveau qu'est-ce que
ça prend qu'est-ce qui sont les
sacrifices et tout ça
ce sont deux alliés même si lorsqu'on
parle en entrevue il se voit comme un
meneur et un arrière ce qui selon moi
est un peut-être un problème
amen et le plus athlétique des deux plus
explosifs les deux sont des deux
accidents athlètes amène et le plus
explosif des deux c'est un athlète
surnaturel un incroyable deuxième saut
un hang time de ouf un premier pas de
ouf ce qui le sépare un peu de son frère
en termes de potentiel ce sont
playmaking si c'est passe des des
grosses qui passeuses
à travers le terrain des rapports je
l'ai vu même en un moment faire un 180
faire un bolet de passe dans le coin
vous allez avoir beaucoup de ça sur
Twitter cette année mais j'ai comme des
gros doutes à savoir si c'est vraiment
le style de jeu que aucun
passé donc
son frère aux arts et un peu plus une
mentalité wall Player est un moins
explosif mais il y en athlétisme un peu
plus fonctionnel meilleur ratio
accélération décélération meilleur
finisseur que son frère aussi il y a un
petit crochet il y a des spin-moves
autour du panier c'est un défenseur
absolument extraordinaire je crois que
aux autres Thompson va être probablement
être peut-être le même meilleur
défenseur de périmètre de cette grave si
ça arrive je l'ai vu l'année dernière en
OTA il se faisait battre souvent par des
gars qui étaient plus bas que lui au sol
mais il était capable de récupérer puis
finir avec le bloc je sais pas qu'est-ce
que ça vaut
parce que oups désolé c'est mon
c'est normal je sais pas qu'est-ce que
ça vaut parce que
over time élite c'est une ligue qui est
sans enjeu ici sans conséquence mais
l'obside est là l'obside est clairement
le [ __ ]
vas-y je te laisse gérer ton ton
téléphone ou quelqu'un là c'est le
signal pour la soupe
amène Thomson qui je
conclue pour moi aussi un meilleur tir
pour le moment qu'aux artenson
pour moi sont très difficiles à regarder
les deux sont sont mauvais mécaniquement
pour l'instant mais je veux dire il est
peut-être un petit poil plus avancé en
tout cas sur les matchs que j'ai vu par
rapport à aux arts la chose dont je suis
le plus sûr c'est qu'ils vont avoir de
la difficulté à avoir du temps de jeu
NBA parce qu'ils vont ils vont avoir des
fautes ils vont avoir des fautes il est
légal de défendre pas de manière
responsable
défendre surtout pas la manière
responsable donc les papas va falloir
qu'il y a des choses qui changent dans
leur manière de jouer parce que je crois
que ça va changer cette année on veut
quand même élite mais donc
apparemment sur le il y a eu de la
progression technique au moins depuis
qu'ils sont arrivés en eartheim Elite
donc why not
pour les jumeaux Tomson
pour vous donner la tendance allez
générale je pense amen est vu quasi
unanimement comme le peut-être le
meilleur prospect des deux et d'ailleurs
c'est lui qui aura le ballon cette année
ils vont jouer dans le même équipe en
over time Elite en début d'année il
sépare les effectifs en trois équipes
les deux vont jouer dans la même équipe
amènent numéro 1
oral ballon et enfin en tout cas je
sauras plus meneur et aux arts quel
numéro 0 jouera plus arrière je vous
donne les numéros parce que ils sont
très difficiles à distinguer l'un de
l'autre sinon si on les connaît pas
c'est vraiment jumeau identique
pour finir
est-ce que vous avez une recommandation
messieurs
une recommandation de match à regarder
parmi tous les prospects qu'on a qu'on a
cité ou non ou d'autres vidéos
d'ailleurs à regarder
et puis je vais vous demander qui vous
préférez alors pas Luka parce qu'il a
pas forcément vu scout il me semble mais
qui vous préférez entre Victory scoots
évidemment je vous demande
allez ben
j'ai jamais vu un prospect comme Victor
j'ai jamais vu un prospecte comme ça
donc c'est encore très théorique mais
pour l'instant Victor très bien suivez
Benoît sur Twitter Benoît Lelièvre
Manu scout Victor un autre
je suis indécis sur sur le 1 mais je
pense que Victor sur le profil est juste
incroyable et ou pas on n'a jamais vu
comme dit ben on n'a jamais vu ça en
fait et oui encore faut avoir de
l'imagination c'est ça on peut le
problème avec Victor l'imagination
l'imagination sur quel poste on
l'imagine sur comment il peut jouer sur
c'est c'est juste insensé quoi
en discutant je passe à discuter avec
d'autres scouts est-ce que les gens se
posent la question ou est-ce que tout le
monde dit bah c'est bon il va être
numéro 1 et tout non je pense qu'il y a
vraiment une question qui qui se pose et
c'est surtout lié au physique de Victor
qui est un peu en Paris
le mentir avec le potentiel énorme mais
je pense que le pari
si Victor cette année il nous montre que
physiquement
c'est beaucoup plus solide qu'avant qui
a eu vraiment un une étape de passer
là-dessus je pense qu'il y aura plus de
discussions très bien merci messieurs
pour pour ce premier numéro de Victor et
les autres c'est on va clore cette
première partie et on va accueillir
notre invité pour avoir notre œil de
l'extérieur
et j'accueille pour ce premier numéro de
Victor et les autres Raphaël Barlow
scout international que vous pouvez lire
sur le site NBA big board welcome refer
Eisen match
[Musique]
[Rires]
voilà c'était Victor et les autres
épisodes du mois d'octobre sur envergure
abonnez-vous sur n'importe quelle
plateforme de d'écoute de podcasts
Spotify Deezer Apple podcast Google
podcast podcast addict voilà j'en oublie
donc abonnez-vous vous aurez la notice
dès qu'un épisode sort comme ça et puis
laissez-nous une note si vous si vous le
voulez ça fait toujours plaisir ça peut
aussi nous permettre de grandir ça fait
aussi nous aider et puis on est à
l'écoute de tout commentaire évidemment
tout amélioration fait de notre mieux
que du côté du son
et en ce qui concerne les joueurs dont
on a parlé ce soir toutes leurs fiches
écrites sont sur envergure.co avec la
photo la taille le poids l'envergure si
elle a été documentée et puis pour
certains déjà des scoutings report tous
les articles dans lesquels on parle
d'eux ça fait généralement plusieurs
années qu'on parle de ces prospects qui
vont être tout en haut de la draft 2023
on se retrouve très bientôt sur les
ondes d'envergure on a un podcast à
venir sur les prospects féminines qui
ont joué cet été pour les équipes de
France Jeunes intéressants pour avoir
une idée de ce que pourrait être le
futur de cette équipe de France on a
tous les vendredis notre live twitch
animé par Hugues et avec également
d'autres personnes on m'a encore step up
cette année sur twitch avec plus de
qualité de films et plus de personnes
qui contribuent également à l'analyse de
films en direct et puis on se retrouve
nous pour un nouvel épisode de Victor et
les autres début novembre allez salut
tout le monde